できないんです いくら頑張ってわがまま言ったら何度か言ったら
まああの この貪瞋無慚無愧の説明では余計なことを言いましたけど
この人間にはやっぱりこのやってはいけないということを世の中にあるやってはいけないことはどうせ人間やりたいものなんですね
ですから 戒律なんかはもう無意味だよというのはもうわかります
気持ちは 気持ちはやりたくないということなんです
でもそれで真理に立つわけじゃないんです
心は育てたければ 嫌なことをやらないといけないんです
勉強したければ 嫌でも学校に行かなくちゃいけないんです
私は遊びたいんだから遊ぶ時間増やしなさいと言っても
それは意味がないんですね
で そこでまあ このやってはいけないことをやりたがる
この余計な勇気 またやる
やりたがるのはいいんだけど
やりたがるのはわかりますけど
やってしまうんですね
学校でタバコ吸ってはいけないというんだけども
吸ってしまうと その勇気
余計な勇気なんですね
そこで母にバレてもまあいいんじゃないかと
先生にバレちゃったら恥ずかしい
恥ずかしいのは大丈夫やという無慚ですね
それで学校からいろいろ厳しく言われたりとかしたらどうなりますかと
両親に怒られたらどうします？全然怖くないんだと
平気だと そういう勇気持ってるし
恥ずかしくないという気持ち
恥ずかしくないという気持ちも持っている
無慚無愧と言うんです
その余計な勇気なんですね
その余計な勇気によって人々が悪いことは必ずする
それから他の経典では
なぜ世の中に悪いことあるかと言ったら
それはこの無慚無愧だよと
無慚無愧があるんだから
心に根拠ない余計な勇気あるんだから
みんな悪いことをするんだと
それでなんで世の中成り立ってるんですかと
普通には世の中っていうのは道徳的に幾らかな平和的に成り立ってるんですね
それはこの慚と愧が働いてるんだと
これは馬車の車輪 2つ浮いてますけど
そこにこの釘 2つ打ってるんですね
車輪が外れないように
その釘 2つのように あるいは車輪 2つで動いているような感じで
世の中は慚と愧で成り立ってるんだと
それなくなっちゃったらむちゃくちゃで
何の法律も何の道徳も成り立たないんだと
そういうことで この心の一つ
またそれ一つ汚れなんですね
その無慚無愧は それ生まれたらその人は悪いことをしたり
物事に執着したりはします
それから 13番目言ってるのは
この心祖としてどんな心祖でしょうかということなんですね
そこでこの阿 savā という
この前の勉強でいろいろことを言いましたから
全部まとめているんです
1 はの 205 ページに阿 savā というものが出てきて
四つ カーマ・アサワ バヴァ・アサワ
ディッターアサワ アヴィッジャ・アサワと
スティーラ・デヴァ カーマ・アサワというのはバヴァ・アサワというのはあの貪
むさぼりですよと ディッターアサワは瞋であって
アヴィッジャ・アサワは愚痴ですね
それからシーラ・ブッタ・パラマーサっていうのは
この修正行とこのテキストで書いているものは
このニッカ章で出ました
三箇章で出ましたけど
それからイダン・サッチャーニ・アビニウェソ
イダン・サッチャーニ・アビニウェソ出てくるのはガンタというところかな
とね そうガンタですね
ガンタというあの 206 ページの 6番目出てくるんですね
これが真実であると呼称する
とか分かります そういうのはあの
それからウパーダーナの中に
あのページのアッダワーダ・ウパーダーナという
邪説の固執というものがあります
で  ページに日本語あります
そういうのはディッティで見であると
まあどんな心性かということは
そんなそんなにまあ厳密に考える必要はないし
だからこちらで言葉違うんだけど
あのの心性をいくつか当てはめるということで
例えばアウィッジャーは無明であって無知でしょうし
それはウッダッチそのまま心性であるし
ヴィチキッチャそのまま疑心性であるし
シーラパタパラーマーサっていうのはまたこちらで書いてましたから
この何でしたっけ 見ですね
これも見の中に入るんだと
そこでまた見 別にまたあるしね
そこでラーガラーガというのは
まあ貪りに入っちゃうし
パティグハは怒りであるし
マーナはマーナという心性が別にあるし
同じ心性に違う違う名前を使ってるんですね
その場所によって そこでこのまあ今まで何を喋ったかと
この第七章で 第七章でまず喋ったのは
この不善の働き 心の不善の部分の働き
最初はこのアーサ 漏のことを言っていた
漏というのは まあその働きを見て漏れるように
心の中に悪いことを漏れてしまって
心が汚れると それからオーガっていうのは放水みたいなもので
暴流ですね その暴流という
あのものすごい感情で出てきて
人間はどうしようもない状態になる
その感情が出てくると
やっぱりつの種類になるんだと
それからヨーガっていうのは釘引きですね
で 釘引きのように我々心が束縛されているものはまたつあるんだと
同じですね 上と下が それまたガンタっていうのは結びついているんだと
結ばれているんだということで
輪廻に 輪廻に結ばれているんだといえば
またつあるんだと それで執着するというならばウパーダーナ
番目 それまたつあるんだと
それでニワーラナ 五蓋ですね
蓋 解脱に蓋をかけているというならば
それでまた六つあるんだと
お経ではつですけど 五蓋ですけど
アビダンマでは無明も入れちゃって六つに入れているんですね
それから心の中に潜在的に睡眠している
あの煩悩があるんだと
それは七種類ですね それから産業的な結という
結ぶということで またまあ結ぶというよりはこのミックスする
混ぜて一緒にするという意味で十種類あるんだ
それで汚れでいえばまた十種類あるんだ
それをどんな言葉で理解したっても
結局出てくるのは同じものなんです
一応知識は明確になるんですね
例えばイダンサッチャーヴィニウェーサ
これは真実だよと と決めつけた人は見ですね
結局は だから見はそういう風に現れますよと理解すれば
もうすごく心の働きに対する明確な理解が生まれてくるんです
でまあ次に行く時間はないんですけど
それから善か不善かという分け方ではなくて
まあ一般的に言えば善のことなんですけど
あの善の心の働き説明しちゃうんですね
で それはまたの日にしましょう
[背景音]